thank you so much good morning everyone
and actually good afternoon to those of
us we came from the east coast and the
best part about coming from east coast
to hear is that you can wake up late and
it's still early and I start get I
started getting emails and phone calls
at four a.m. this morning so anyway
today I'm going to be talking about one
of the major research activities that
have been going on in my lab these past
few years which is which deals with the
opportunity in biological networks what
kind of challenges it brings to us as
computer scientists and what kind of
opportunities that I'm hoping that it
will open up for the biologists and as
we all know the biological networks
describe how different molecules
interact with each other and there is no
need to motivate this group about the
importance of analyzing this data but
when I read the literature on studying
biological network network data in
pretty much all the literature that I
came across with you see this common
pattern that we make a strong assumption
that we have a precise knowledge of the
topology of the interactions but in
reality we don't there's a lot of noisy
data there's a lot of missing data and
there's also an inherent uncertainty
that comes from the nature of this data
so we don't really know what the
topology looks like so just because two
molecules exist at the same time in the
same place that doesn't mean that they
are going to be interacting all the time
now this uncertainity arises from a
bunch of reasons such as invitations
genetic epigenetic mutations the size of
the molecules like the larger molecules
maybe are going to be less likely to
interact with each other than smaller
molecules because of mobility reasons or
the abundance of the molecules that are
interacting in a recent paper we even
have observed that there is a
relationship between the interaction the
chances to interact between the
molecules and the timing of the
replication of different parts of the
DNA today I'm not going to be talking
about the reasons behind uncertainty I'm
going to be talking about the
implications
now when you typically we represent a
biological network using a graph am a
certain biological knitter we are going
to represent it with a graph with
probabilities attached to it and here is
a solar example which will hopefully
give us a feeling of where the
challenges arise from in this small
example we have three node to
interactions and the numbers on these
interactions indicate hypothetically the
probability of observing those
interactions 0.3 and 0.6 now because we
don't know what the actual topology
looks like maybe both of the
interactions are going to be missing and
topology will look like this and this
would happen with a certain probability
which we can calculate by multiplying
the probability of absence of those
edges I understand there is a assumption
that's being made that the interactions
are independent which I'll come to it
later or maybe the left ability the VC
exists
so in the underlying network bc the way
that it is described there is a set of
possible interactions and each of these
interactions may or may not happen so if
it is not drawn here it means that it
doesn't exist so thanks for pointing
that out or it could be any of these
other configurations so it went a little
bit for it but each of these
configurations happen with a certain
probability which we can calculate and
it gives us the set of all possible
worlds you add the probable it is it's
going to give you one as you can see the
core challenge that arises from this
model is that if you have n
probabilistic interactions you can have
2 to the power and different
deterministic topologies and we call
each of these typologies a deterministic
topology and whatever question you are
asking about this biological network
your answer can be may or may not be
different for each of these two
apologies that you observe and clearly
we cannot enumerate all possible to
apologies and so the problem
independently for each of them and give
some kind of an answer so this can take
a lot of time so when you move from the
deterministic concept for network to the
probabilistic concept as I many explain
any few minutes a lot of problems that
we cause their own biological networks
and we take it granted that we have
actually sold it some of them easily
some of them not so easily suddenly
become a lot harder and here are some
examples to those questions like the
simplest question maybe is the
characterization of the network topology
what is the degree distribution what is
the joint degree distribution these are
very easy task for deterministic network
topologies identifying pathways is there
a path from here to here aligning a pair
of networks now this is a harder problem
or counting motives this is also a very
hard problem in deterministic network
but regardless of whether your problem
is easy or hard in the deterministic no
me the moment you realize that you don't
really know the precise knowledge of the
topology of network e all of them
becomes significantly harder and on top
of all of these problems lies the issue
of how do I even model this uncertainty
in the biological networks so what we do
in this project is that we came up with
some kind of
mathematical model which adapts to each
of these problems in various ways and in
our model we don't really look at
biological networks as graphs anymore we
look at them as sets of equations and
model each of these equations by tiny
tiny polynomials and then with the help
of these polynomials the way that the
variables and the coefficients are set
up we try to capture the relationship
between different molecules about how
they interact with each other and
hopefully it's going to be all clear in
the next few slides so I'm going to
start with which i think is the easiest
problem which is counting the degree of
a note so if i have a deterministic
network if i give you a network now
forget about the probabilities for a
second what is the degree of this node
it's three simple if there are
probabilities associated with this node
what is the degree of this node we don't
know it could be 0 1 2 or 3 and there is
a probability for observing each of
these values and obviously we don't want
to create all different combinations and
count how many in how many different
ways I can observe two edges 31 edge
that's going to take a lot of time so
what how can we approach to this problem
what we did is that for each of these
probabilistic edges we created a tiny
edge polynomial in the following form
there's a variable Z and the coefficient
of this variable is equal to the
probability of observing that edge and
the constant is that is 1 minus that
probability which is the absence
probability so similarly every Edge has
its own tiny polynomial and now we have
our initial set of polynomials set up
and then you can take these polynomials
and multiply them with each other it's a
very simple polynomial multiplication
with tiny polynomials and you get a
polynomial of degree 4 which is one more
than the number of edges that you have
in no time I can get this result and we
can prove mathematically that the
coefficient of any variable like Z to
the power K precisely gives us the
probability of observing exactly K edges
under this model without any
approximation
now what about the joint degree
distribution now here the problem
becomes a little more challenging
because now these two nodes they share
an edge so which means that if this edge
exists is going to exist for both of
them if it is absent it's going to be
absent for both of them so I cannot use
a exactly the same idea but I can borrow
from that idea if I simply create these
polynomials one for node you and one for
node V if I multiply the polynomials I'm
going to get the incorrect result
because of the dependency but what i can
do is i can remove the edge first which
creates that dependency and then
reinsert it but this time with a new
polynomial which adjust which is adjust
as saw that this edge exists for both of
them is captured by adding these two
variables 1 z 1 controlling the node u +
z2 controlling node we at the same time
and we can prove also mathematically
that if you multiply these polynomials
the product gives you the joint degree
distribution without any approximation
so here are two simple problems that we
could use with our polynomial
transformation and something that
seemingly is exponential in time but it
actually is not exponential in time and
as we keep working on different problems
and doing these transformations you are
going to see that some of the problems
will remain on the polynomial domain in
terms of complexity and some of them
actually will continue to be exponential
but the exponent the exponential part is
going to become significantly cheaper
here's a result that we got using the by
incorporating the probabilities of the
interactions what you see here is the
the likelihood of six different
mathematical models which are listed
here poison exponential gamma power low
log normal stretch polynomial these are
standard distribution models that are
used in the literature to fit degree
distribution so we fit this degree
distribution to the protein interaction
networks of five different organisms
drosophila c elegans is cerevisiae
Helicobacter and e-coli P and D here
indicate the probabilistic and
deterministic model so what you are
going to see in this table is that
consistently in all the insta
is that the probabilistic method the
probable incorporating the probabilities
will give you much better likelihood
than the deterministic one so you can
fit much better by taking the
interaction probabilities into
consideration and a second observation
which may be more important is when you
focus on the I don't know if it is
visible from there but there are some
highlighted entries in each row it means
that it is the most likely distribution
for that specific instance in two out of
the five cases the probabilistic and the
deterministic models agree on which
model explains this network topology the
best but in three of them they disagree
so not only you can find more likely
results but also you find the result
that's different so our conclusion was
that from here was that incorporating
the probabilities can give you some
different result than not incorporating
it and then the additional cost is I
have just shown you is minimal
not the second problem which I'm sure
all of you will be familiar with is the
network alignment there's a lot of work
on network alignment I'm not going to go
over them that we don't have enough time
but I'm going to explain it based on the
ice rank method which is one of the
classical methods to address the network
alignment problem and at the heart of
the eyes are admitted it has various
steps but its heart lies the concept of
support matrix where we say how much if
I align this node with that other node
how much does it support the alignment
of my neighbors so if I'm going to a
line let's say mode are three with the
other node are three how much does it
support my neighbors and in the
classical I should I admitted what it
data is that they will you look at your
neighbors if this is a directed graph
you'll get your backward neighbors how
many backward neighbors do I have two on
one side and one on the other side so
how many different combinations do I
have 2 times 12 so how many forward
neighbors do I have one and two how many
different ways to map my forward
neighbors for two so two plus two is
four so your support the support of
aligning the blue are three with the red
are three becomes split into four
different pairs of forward and neck with
forward and backward node pairs and this
is an and the algorithm uses this matrix
to align the network well of course if
this is a probabilistic network we don't
know which of these edges exists or not
so we can have different number of
backward neighbors and different number
of forward neighbors under different
scenarios so we don't have a clear
region of how much support we are going
to give to each one of them so to deal
with that we actually have borrowed from
the degree and joint degree distribution
polynomials and we can create the
polynomial for one of the notes from one
of the network and the other polynomial
for the other node in the other network
and simply by multiplying these two
polynomials we can get all combinations
of I and J labor pairs that are aligned
with each other in a matrix simply in
this product every anywhere that we see
for example
Square + y1 if you multiply the
exponents plant one it shows you the
scenario in which there are two
neighbors and one neighbors that are
alive so your support is going to be
split into two places and everywhere
where you see this number six it shows
you that there's a scenario in which six
of my neighbors are alive so all you
need to do is just take those scenarios
it has 1 over 6 if it is 6 than your
support is split into six pieces and you
multiply it with the probability of
observing that and you can get a
probabilistic support matrix this way
without any approximation again and then
we have implemented it I'm going to skip
the details and just show you some
results so we align protein interaction
networks of different organisms using
the eyes rank algorithm on the
deterministic network by ignoring all
the interaction probabilities and we
have used exactly the same our algorithm
by just including the interaction
probabilities on the same data and for
each environment we calculated something
called functional coherence functional
coherence means that you locate the gene
ontology terms it calculates how much
does the gene ontology term of one node
that is mapped with another node match
with each other so the more their they
share the same node the same annotations
the better the more functionally
coherent they are so we calculate the
functional coherence of the result with
at without the probable probability is
taken into consideration using exactly
the same algorithm take the ratio and
this is what we get in increasing order
of the ratio out of the roughly 90
different alignment examples about a
couple of them like four or five of them
the deterministic version actually
managed to find better results but in
all the remaining like about ninety
percent of the result incorporating the
probabilities gave us much more coherent
alignment results and in some of them
actually the ratio this is in log scale
more than an order of magnitude better
than the other one
then we looked into a third problem
which actually you're going to see that
it's actually a simple problem in the
deterministic domain but it becomes a
very very difficult problem in the
probabilistic domain so in this problem
we want to find out if a signal that
arrives at a starting point is going to
arrive at a terminal point in the
underlying biological problem that we
are considering for this problem for was
the signaling interactions where you
have an extracellular molecule that
binds to a membrane receptor whether the
signal is going to arrive at the nucleus
at the transcription factor so you can
roughly think of it like that from the
membrane receptor to the transcription
factor and sometimes we use the term
receptor and reporter to indicate the
starting and terminal nodes I can post
the same problem as a single source
single destination problem by hype into
using a hypothetical gene which has a
outgoing edge to all the receptors and
the hypothetical terminal node which has
an incoming edge from all the terminal
nodes so this is a very easy problem can
I reach from force to destination all I
need to do is just run some
breadth-first search their first search
algorithm and I can give a yes or no
answer but if these edges are
probabilistic then suddenly the problem
falls into the Sharpie complete problem
class we cannot roll it in polynomial
time
it's remained in this class regardless
of whether it's a multi-source
multi-destination or single source
single destination problem so dealing
with this problem actually was harder
because there was so much dependency
between the past and edges and nodes
that we need to capture and yet be
precise at the same time so we deal
without with it in several steps in the
first step this is this very small
hypothetical example with four notes
five edges this is the receptor and
reporter node in the first step we
simply find alternative ways should this
be a deterministic network alternative
ways to reach from start to the terminal
node 1 & 2 3 & 4 352 these are some
alternative ways and for simplicity I'm
going to represent all these pads in
tabular form where each row is a pad and
each column is an edge and you have an X
if that edge belongs to that path step
number two find the minimum cuts a
minimal cut is a set of edges such that
after you remove it you separate the
source from the destination and it's
minimal it means that there is no subset
of these edges whose removal separates
from source to destination like one and
three for example 24 so there's a bunch
of such minimal cuts and again J for the
sake of simplicity I'm not represented
in the same tabular form so this is just
the first step and then comes our
polynomial transformation again so this
time my polynomials form is different in
two different ways that you might have
noticed for every edge I have two
variables instead of one variable one of
these variables is going to capture the
scenario in which the edge exists which
is X I and the other one captures the
scenario in which it is absent and these
variables are multiplied with the
corresponding probabilities the second
difference that you might have noticed
is that instead of a single variable
every Edge has its own variable like X 1
X 2 X 3 so we actually have plenty of
variables and we need all those
variables to actually capture the depend
seas between different paths and in my
running example I'm going to make just
for the sake of simplicity I'm going to
assume that all the probabilities are
equal to 0.5 but that assumption really
has no influence on the outcome so i
think my first edge polynomial simply
write it down and then the second edge
polynomial and i multiply them together
and i get a polynomial which has
different combinations of xinyi s but
here you might have noticed that one of
these terms which is the last term here
x1 x2 actually corresponds to the
scenario in which I can definitely reach
so I don't care what happens from this
point I can always reach so I replace
this term with a new term that has a
very special variable X star and this X
star is going to be sucking up all the
terms that it gets multiplied with
because now we are in a world in which I
can reach from source to destination so
by doing that it's going to simplify the
polynomials form and slow down if the
growth of this polynomial as you
multiply it with more and more of these
unit polynomials now let's take the
Third Age polynomial
now obviously when I multiply it the X
star is going to take these terms and
transform it into X star we call it
collapse ation that these terms are
going to collapse but on top of that
something else is going to happen then y
3 is going to get multiplied with let's
say why one you are going to be falling
into this row where you have a cut fits
active it means that now I'm in a world
in which I cannot reach from source to
destination no matter what happens so
for all those cases I'm going to
collapse them into my second special
variable which I called y scarf y star
so both of these variables when they get
multiplied with somebody they collapse
those terms into either X star and y
star so you have fever and fever terms
so when you must continue this
multiplication eventually you are
guaranteed to end up with only two terms
instead of an exponential number of
terms and the coefficient of the term X
star is guaranteed to be the probability
that you can reach from you're forced to
destination
so this was good only if you can
collapse and then we observed it as your
graphs get larger sometimes you cannot
collapse as fast as you want and your
polynomial doubles doubles and then it
gets out of control to deal with that we
use another characteristics of the real
biological networks which is that they
are usually sparse for sparse networks
usually you can find some cuts which we
call node separators which can separate
the starting notes from the terminal
node and also they have to satisfy some
other properties which are in the paper
if things that's why those properties
then I can we prove that we can show the
left side and the right side of the
problem independent of each other this
way we can literally scale to hundreds
of nodes and edges as long as I can find
these cuts but then for a different
application for a different problem we
came across with a network which for
which we could not even find a nice cut
so our bottleneck was the largest load
separator was too large to actually
collapse so how do I deal with that case
in which my network is both large and
deaths so if my network is not going to
partition if it is dense how about we
sparse Phi it that's what we thought and
then we decided to sample a fraction of
the edges let's say fifty percent of the
edges which are shown in this example
with green and red color and 4000 of
those edges that I select I flip a coin
proportional to the probability of
existence of that age if it comes heads
I keep it if it comes tails I remove it
so red edges are the ones that I remove
it in this example so if i remove an
edge what does it mean obviously i get
rid of one of those polynomials so my
polynomial problem becomes smaller but
more importantly when i remove that edge
now this node can be pushed out of the
load separator making my note separator
size small which was the bottleneck of
this problem and i remove this other guy
and the corresponding node can also be
pushed out of the node separator now
instead of having two problems of size
three each I end up having three
problems of size two each and it is
exponential in the size of this problem
so reducing it by some amount actually
exponentially cuts down my cross
and obviously the last benefit is that
for the green edges which are guaranteed
to exist because now they guaranteed
they exist instead of a polynomial with
two terms I have a polynomial one term
they also slow down the growth so anyway
using this we could solve it of course
now you are inaccurate you need to run
it a bunch of times to calculate
confidence interval in your result I'm
going to show you some results
interesting results and finish in two
minutes I have more slice than there so
I'm gonna just show this one and one
more is up so here we use our reach
ability algorithm on two different
networks erv B&W NT and instead of
calculating reach ability to the genes
we calculate reach ability to gene
ontology terms what does it mean these
genes are associated with different
terms let's say that jinhwan and gene
two are associated with term t1 then we
calculate the probability of reaching
two genes g1 orgy so we set those as the
target genes that becomes the
reachability probability for that
specific function and then we calculate
the reachability probability for all the
terms that exist in these two networks
and this is the result that we get in
decreasing order of probability now
should we look at these networks without
the interaction probability is the only
thing that you are going to see is that
one of them has 90 terms then the other
one has 50 something terms and WN t has
is serving a lot of a lot more functions
than ERBB by taking the probabilities
into consideration we can see that
although w and he has a lot of functions
that it's serving many of them are
actually being executed with a small
probability than ERBB with those field
for fever functions many of them are
having a high probability so it made it
possible for us to see that and the
other result then I want to show is
actually here so here we use the human
transcriptional regulatory network and
for different source and destination
pairs we calculate the reachability
probability so what you see here in
every row is the interaction
probabilities calculated for different
specific cancer type lung cancer ovarian
cancer and so on and so forth and each
column correspond
to a pair of source and destination
apoptosis cell cycle and p53 networks
obviously the first thing that you are
going to notice when you look at it here
is that certain cancer types are
clustered together in different networks
that's a good answer but I think the
more interesting result is if you focus
on some of these columns in which in
which one of these cancer types like
here differentiate from the rest of the
cancer types significantly so what is
that source and destination pair for
which the one cancer has a significantly
higher ritually than the other cancer
types when you look at these you see for
example here we see pyaar ka CA which is
actually associated with the this
present with the spread of the and the
severity of the the lung cancer so we
hypothesize that with the help of this
algorithm by taking the probabilities
into consideration of course we can
capture phenotype specific signatures
that are maybe not so easy to calculate
without calculating the probability
because without the probabilities all
these networks are going to look
identical to each other so I'm going to
skip my last problem which actually this
is an ongoing problem so I don't even
have the solution posted here so if you
are my students are working on it so the
take-home message is that taking the
probabilities into consideration can
help us find out things that are
impossible to find out without taking
into consideration the second take on
message is that it may look like the
problems are getting significantly
harder but there's often a way to deal
with that through this kind of a
transformation this is my lab some of
them have graduated and I have a couple
of new students whose pictures are not
with me so all the credit goes to them
thank you so much your polynomials are
the same thing as what is usually called
interacting function nice probability
generating functions yes and not the way
that you set up changes from one problem
to another problem because you have to
do it in a way that it captures the
relationship between the interactions in
the right way by conditioning that's
right and I actually didn't even have it
time to talk about how we get rid of
this independent probability assumption
but there is a way to set up those
probability generating functions which
creates the dependency between
neighboring edges the difficult problem
was depending on the fact that you
consider directed graphs while they know
for most of the interaction would not
necessarily direct so they actually we
consider both directed and undirected
graphs stressed at some of these
examples for examples that I'm giving
they are drawn in that way for the
reachability problem for us it's easier
to work with the directed graphs because
of the concept of the most separators
they have to satisfy some properties if
it is undirected there is always a
backward edge which makes it impossible
to find North separators aside from that
problem it is actually independent of
whether it is directed or undirected
which exact the problem is shown to be
sharp a complete this to reach ability
problem this is a directed graph I don't
think so to the best of my knowledge
actually stays in the same class but
practically it gets actually harder
because the number of paths increases
when you have an undirected set of edges
one more you clarify where the
interaction probabilities come from and
the cancer application I sure sure I
didn't even mention that because i was
watching the time actually we also had
another there are three different ways
to do it annexure out of these three
ways one of them is actually something
that we have published ourselves in that
specific problem it's we used our own
algorithm to calculate the interaction
probability there is based on the
transcription data based on the gene
transcription data what we do is we'll
get the correlation between the
transcription patterns let's say of lung
cancer patients between this sword and
the destination for a lot of source
destination pairs and then we solve the
inverse problem of reach ability
actually we say hey what should be the
individual probabilities so that the
reachability probability is going to be
equal or proportional to the correlation
between them correlation expressions get
is right so we use and then the other
two methods actually they also one of
the most accusers correlation it's by
Road Sharon and some of quarters and
then they use clustering coefficient
publications from PubMed and the
transcription information and there's a
third way we use the one that we have
developed ourselves
now we can take more questions on